when you were 90 you rarely talk about
what you did you always talk about what
you didn't do if you were lucky enough
and if you wanted to get inspired to
spend just a little time with a 75 to 90
year old that you don't know and you
listen what she or he will talk about is
what they didn't do I should have
married Ricky Thompson I wish I did
something different in my career the
thing that impacted me as a workaholic
and someone who's really ambitious I
wish I spent more time with my kids that
hit me hard you were not born for a long
time and you're going to be dead forever
the moments we have here are
small
the art skills were the things that I
focused on and I think our society has
focused on for a very very very long
time the IQ of it all the grades of it
all in athletics the speed the strength
the math which is amazing because it's a
major part of our world and for me that
was work ethic like you know since I was
14 spending 12 hours a day in my dad's
liquor store in Springfield New Jersey
not too far away was just how I grew up
I worked every weekend I worked every
summer vacation my parents were
gangsters I don't know if you guys
remember but the last day of school
starting around Middle School was a half
a day my parents used to pick me up at
that half a day and bring me to the
store so I could work the end of the
second day they didn't even give me that
half day
it was work ethic and I always
understood that that would do something
but as I've gone through the journeys of
my career
other things started to become obvious
to me which was these things are going
well for me and yes I'm working hard and
yes I'm doing the thing but I have a
feeling a lot of this is coming from the
things that I was also gifted
predominantly for my mother which are
the soft skills the things that we did
not grow how many people here by show of
hands are over 40 raise your hands
amazing the majority of the room let's
clap it up for some of the youngsters in
here
um
so what some of the youngsters in here
definitely don't realize is for the over
40 year old crowd in here we didn't talk
about empathy we didn't talk about you
know some of these softer traits in hard
places
you know we didn't talk about that in
business it was you know who you know
nice guys finish last
was a thing that a lot of us grew up
hearing and something in the last 15
years clicked for me where I just didn't
believe that to be true
I didn't believe it to be true because
I'm nice and I'm gonna finish first
and I would watch others and I started
realizing actually a lot of people that
had ridiculous Talent
who weren't nice were actually losing a
lot more than they could be winning
it seemingly looked good back to being a
big sports fan they were winning at
halftime
they were up 21-0 because they had that
edge those sharp elbows but something
became very clear to me that there was a
lot of other parts of the formula to get
to the highest level and more
importantly and I know this matters to a
lot of people in this room
if you were gonna lead
if you were going to be a leader and
obviously there's leadership in business
I'm a CEO of 2000 employees obviously
there's leadership in Services both
whether it's military police fire like
that's obvious but every person in here
will taste leadership in their entire
lives it will happen you're either an
older sibling
you know I would argue that most of my
leadership was ingrained in to me by
being the oldest of two siblings
especially in growing up in the 80s in
an immigrant household it was different
you took care of them you know back to
the youngsters not knowing this is crazy
I'm about to tell you something back in
the day we used to go outside and play
and our parents had no idea what we were
doing
by the time I was seven in Edison New
Jersey I was outside nine hours a day
and my mom had no clue what I was doing
and what I knew at seven was I had to
take care of my four-year-old sister and
you started learning those things but
then even if you don't have the
Serendipity of being the oldest you will
lead because many people will taste the
beauty of being a parent you want to
talk about real leadership you want to
talk about real fear you want to lead
and you because that person that you
gave birth to is the person you love
more than anybody in the world and so as
I started looking at the world over the
last 15 years I like to think I like to
observe I like watching people
it started getting obvious to me that
these softer skills mattered but here's
where some of these skills kick in I was
giving a lot of thought to like what do
I want to talk about a couple things and
the framework of the room we're in one
thing I think a lot about is empathy
right empathy is a funny word it wasn't
really talked about like I said earlier
for just not a we've no word I heard in
the first 20 25 years of my life
it's starting to pop up a little bit
here but I think it's very much
misunderstood you know empathy
oftentimes comes from a place of like
feeling compassion for the other person
having feelings for them and I think it
makes sense when you're a leader to have
empathy for the people that you are
managing or leading but I think for
happiness for lack of anxiety for joy
for the journey that I want for every
person in this room
one of the things to really think about
is having empathy for the person above
you
one of the things that I've seen bring
enormous happiness
to many people in my organizations the
companies I invest in the companies that
I run and then just organizations Sports
organizations
service organizations is when you in
this room
let's just do a four instance when
you're working on something as an
engineer here right or a physicist on
something and you're working on it for
seven years and you've got it finally
working in real life not in the lab
and then on a one hour's notice on a one
seconds noticed
we're shifting strategy and you're no
longer doing that there's enormous
frustration
you're in the trenches and somebody in a
boardroom is making a call and you're
frustrated
I think about that a lot why because I
think that's the exact moment where if
the people in this room deployed empathy
to the people above them
if you think about being frustrated with
your manager or your leader or their
leaders leader or there's leaders leader
I don't know if you've heard but
everyone's got a boss
and the guys in this room really know
what I'm talking about
everybody's got a boss
no matter what your position looks like
and so I think about you know when I
come to a talk whether
the room is this way that way left right
business startup entrepreneurs high
schools military like it's all the same
thing for me up here right this second
can I say one thing
that one person in this room has not
heard in that way that makes them
actually act on it to make their life
better period
I know the framework of a lot of
people's professional careers in this
room
and I know that disproportionately the
quickest way for them to get happier day
to day
is to actually put them in the boots or
the shoes or the sneakers of the people
above them parallel to them and Below
them below them comes natural
below them comes natural there's a sense
of like okay this person's reporting to
that kind of natural not everyone's good
at it we all know that
but that comes a little more natural but
above you
or six rungs above you
that comes hard
because you think they should be working
for you which is true one of the reasons
everything has worked for me
professionally is every morning I wake
up including today on a groggy day on
the East Coast
I wake up and say I work for those 2 000
people globally not the other way around
true leadership is only based on that
humility I don't care how many things
you have on your thing
do you have the humility to know that
you work for them easy to do it for the
flag
because it's Theory It's Not a Human
Being when it becomes human it gets
harder
it becomes more real
right all of a sudden you have to Care
on an individual basis and you all know
this every person left right below to
you is different
the ones that come easy to you that are
like you is easy
but the accountability to deal with
what's hard
is the game leadership
I see this all the time there's a lot of
people who've gone through the Journey
of doing the craft
and then elevating up and then having to
manage
the people doing the craft that's a
tough transition for a lot of people
it's a lot harder a lot of people think
I didn't sign up for this
for example in my industry I have all
these people that run media
MIT math kids out to wazoo
they love their headphones and their
work they come to me when they get
promoted like wait a minute
I don't want to talk to Sally about her
being sad
I'm here to run media I'm like you're
not
you're not
and so like I get the transition of
getting into feelings
and boy do we love to judge once we
become a leader back to the over 40 year
old crowd versus some of the people
under 25 we love to judge gen Z
I just want to remind all the people
this is my favorite thing going on
Sidetrack real quick I'll just go over
here for a second my number one favorite
conversation in the world right now is
Boomers
all frustrated and angry at gen Z
when they're the ones who created them
and somebody complaining hard the other
day about his son I'm like maybe if you
didn't give him an eighth place trophy
he wouldn't be entitled
yeah
I really hate eighth place trophies
I don't even like the silver and bronze
medal I think you should leave that [__]
when they give it to you right on the
desk
but that's another story for another day
listen
if you leave here with anything this
morning and I want to do a lot of q a
all Yap here but I really want to get
into the details of these philosophies
these are not just words to me
accountability
like to me I'm not here to do anything
other than to make somebody happier for
the rest of their lives I can promise
you right now the fastest way for every
person here and I'm talking whether
you're dealing with something
professionally right now whether you're
dealing something with a loved one
Leisure friendship like life life
the quickest way to be dramatically
happier the second you walk out of here
is to fall in love with accountability
this is a very interesting framework
do you need me
interesting and I'm gonna I'm gonna say
this slow because I get worried because
sometimes this screws people up it
actually makes them upset with
themselves
this is very subtle I'm gonna go
accountability
it's somehow you can get into a place in
your mind
where you realize everything you're
unhappy about right this second is 100
your fault without
without you then judging and beating
yourself up and thinking you suck and
having insecurity let me say it again if
you can wake up tomorrow and whether
you're upset in your marriage if you're
disappointed with your child if you're
not happy with your career if you don't
have enough money like whatever it is
if you can go 100 into accountability
you will be stunned how quickly your
life will turn around the trick that I'm
trying to figure out how to communicate
better is what I've noticed when I've
been on this rant for a decade of like
everything that you're upset about is
100 your fault I didn't realize how many
people were so deeply insecure that that
path puts them into a place where
they're beating themselves up the reason
the world right now is pointing so many
fingers is because everyone's judging
themselves
you want to really get going give
yourself a break
love yourself a little bit more be a
little bit nicer to yourself there's not
a human in this room a human in this
room that hasn't made a ton of mistakes
we have so demonized a misstep or a loss
back to apaley's Trophies exist because
we didn't want our kids to cry when they
lost the only reason I'm standing here
is I cried after I lost my entire
childhood
we have to be nicer to ourselves but I'm
telling you right now
if you can get out of the
finger-pointing business and get into
the thumbs business
your life will be dramatically better
like dramatically because here's the
problem the reason everyone's unanxed
the reason everyone's so challenged
is when you point fingers
you just admitted that you're not in
control
period
that accountability
is such a powerful drug and it is
something we have lost our way with we
just have we need to get there you can't
tell me anything you can come up here
and fully explain why it's not working
and I can look you dead enough right
here with your current job and I could
say quit
you could
you are in control unlike where I and my
parents were born you're born in a place
where you can quit and you can change
your career you can move you can do
anything and the second you start
understanding that truth is the second
everything opens up
another thing I've been thinking a ton
about
which is how do you balance these traits
that were in the book how do you balance
confidence with humility
really hard similar to what I just
talked about which is like be fully
accountable but don't beat yourself up
another thing to think about is the
power of humility there's a lot of
people in here winning and Rising
unfortunately as people win and Rise
they sometimes get a little high on
their own Supply
they get a little bit frothy and think
they're a little special
they start to lose you like that one
there's some people feeling it out there
I like how some people are looking at
each other
laughs
there is such a danger in losing your
relationship with humility
there's such a danger I'm a very public
figure I have
tens and tens and tens of millions of
followers across social media every time
I post
I get unlimited people that leave a
comment of a goat emoji that I'm the
greatest of all time
I also have many people that say you
suck you're a charlatan who do you think
you are every post
a lot of my friends who've gone through
this journey with me other people who've
got a lot of awareness out there many
people quit along the way they can't
deal with the negative comments many of
you don't post anymore because you just
don't want to deal with negativity many
of you have not started posting about
some of your interest the Devils who
play my Rangers in this playoff series I
caught that logo you know
many of you have not even started your
journey
because you're scared of the judgment
one of the reasons that I can continue
to do what I do publicly is because
every time someone says nice things to
me I can't hear them
every goat Emoji I get does not register
what's important about that is if you
can't hear them cheering
you can't hear them booing
too many of us
right in this room right now in our
personal professional lives
are doing things and acting
predominantly based on the opinions of
others
the amount of human beings
that are living life today
worrying about the opinions of people
that they don't even like
is devastating
and by the way those people that you
don't like
aren't Anonymous people in the comments
they're your co-workers they're your
siblings
they're your parents
you know it's hard
it's the truth
the reality is this though
I think a lot about this every day
you were not born for a long time
and you're going to be dead forever
the moments we have here are
small
one thing I would recommend everyone in
this room to do as an action is to spend
a lot more time with 80 to 100 year olds
that are not your family members
if anyone here can find the luxury of
maybe living close to a retirement home
and providing some service to it maybe
you have a neighbor
for me given how busy I am I usually do
it when I'm traveling if I get lucky
enough to sit with somebody or at the
gate at the airport if I find a good 90
year old that looks like Yoda I'll roll
up on him start just talking
the thing all of you would realize if
you I mean this is really important back
to like people love talking about like
living a fulfilled life service this and
that there's so many little things we
can do
like if you close your eyes right now
and think about do I have a neighbor 80
to 175 to 100 next door the answer is
many do like
just like bring something over Flowers
okay you know stuff that we used to do
you know but you're doing it for selfish
reasons yeah you're being selfless and
doing something kind and I promise you
and I think this will land with a lot of
people boy there's an 83 year old that's
living by themselves in an apartment
complex really appreciates someone
coming over ringing the doorbell and
saying what's up and giving them you
know some flowers or a cake or something
but you're not being selfless
you're being selfless and selfish what
you're looking to do is build that
relationship because let me promise you
one thing if you start spending your
time with somebody that's actually lived
life
85 87 and it's not carrying the baggage
because they want to actually like
Razzle your mother or tell you what your
dad's doing wrong you know that
grandparent life is a little different
there's baggage there you need a neutral
third party 86 year old in your life
you're going to learn something real
powerful that I'd like to talk about
right now which is I live my life every
day
completely based on what I've learned
from them which is the following when
you are 90 you rarely talk about what
you did
you always talk about what you didn't do
if you are lucky enough and if you want
to get inspired to spend just a little
time six hours 10 hours this year
with a 75 to 90 year old that you don't
know
and you listen and you talk what she or
he will talk about is what they didn't
do
you should have married Ricky Thompson
I wish and this is a big one I wish I
did something different in my career
you know the thing that impacted me as a
workaholic and someone who's really
ambitious I wish I spent more time with
my kids that hit me hard when I started
doing this in my 30s 40s that was like
I'm like that's the one that's my Danger
that's my danger and it shifted me it
shifted me
so I asked all of you whether you're a
youngster whether you're in the first
quarter or entering the fourth quarter
or anywhere in between it's never too
late to get better
it's never too late to fight for more
happiness ever
it's never a bad idea about so many of
my friends at 50 60 just wrapping it up
they're like Gary all the stuff you talk
about I'm done I'm like done what
you're gonna live to 90. you're 56
you're gonna live another 40 years
you're done
should never be done should never be
done to not regret you should never be
done to be happier
something I want to touch on that I knew
I wanted to touch on here it was my
biggest emotional vulnerability
professionally which was Candor a lot of
you here
one of the biggest thing in this
environment that people struggle with is
Candor some of you like me don't want to
deliver Candor because you don't want to
hurt people's feelings you're actually
non-confrontational you like really love
the person that you're about to talk to
that stinks at something and you don't
want to say it and you like I used to
dance like a ballerina I would dance I
had something to say to somebody it
would take three minutes and I was in
there for 45 minutes like I'm Fred
Astaire I would dance
and never get to it and what did that do
for me over 20 years it led to me having
very awkward firings and all sorts of
when I think back to any person the tens
of thousands of people that have worked
for me for the last 30 years the only
ones the only ones
the the hundred people that most don't
like me all same issue I wasn't able to
be candorous with them and I manipulated
it in my own mind of like they should be
happy that they're still here because
they stink and how does Johnny not see
that he stinks I shouldn't have to tell
him I should have told him
because I didn't do any favors the
problem was my whole childhood and my
whole early upbringing anybody that was
in my life that was good at Candor was
horrible at delivering it
the Candor was delivered in venom
and I wasn't able to take the vehicle
that the Candor was being delivered in
separate from the value of candor
so what I did was what I always do in
the world I market and I brand
when I realized how big of a
vulnerability this was for me I branded
myself I created a word and a structure
for me to help me and that's how I came
up with kind candor
when I tell you for a lot of leaders in
here for the organizations in the back
for the organizations in the front and
for everybody in between including again
the thing I believe which is a lot of
these things are impacting your
relationships and your real life not
just your professional life
I highly recommend people
especially the ones that are DNA wise
similar to me who struggle with telling
people the truth when they're
disappointed in them you must find a way
to get down the path of candor
is led to the lack of Candor has led to
every negative thing that's ever
happened in my life singly
that's how big of a deal this is
so I impose I I pray I push all of you
to realize how big of a deal this is
but
here's why Candor scares me there are
many people in this room as managers who
use Candor as an excuse
to be nasty
to Raz to manipulate
and so it's a very very very dangerous
thing I'm just being candorous with you
to help you
um
you know Gary I'm just keeping it real
I'm like yeah real negative
real manipulative
Candor is a tricky one but if you can
understand the kindness part
all of you know this you've either been
on the receiving end or you've been the
deliverer of a message and you know when
it didn't land you're like damn that did
not go the way I wanted
it is always because of your
relationship with candor
no question after watching this be the
framework of my companies getting the
feedback after the book's been out and
just kind of watching I really believe
in this concept of kind Candor I really
believe if you understand it
if you can really deliver the
challenging news with a little honey
instead of vinegar
if you've really got the intent for that
person to win I believe that kind Candor
really really matters and I highly
recommend you start working on your
relationship with Canada I when I tell
you when I think about competitiveness
10 out of 10 accountability nine out of
ten right patience
this is a big one I Crush patients
everybody wants everything now which is
why they don't get what they want
patience 10 out of 10. kind Candor today
in front of you 4 out of ten
literally was a one out of ten or two
out of ten three years ago four out of
ten let me just tell you where how big
of a deal this is from one out of ten to
four out of ten it's doubled my business
it's made the closest relationships that
I have my sister my my family
3x better
I just know that Candor is a big one I
know that people really struggle with it
because it's a hardcore DNA trait and
for the managers in here and leaders in
here it's a tricky one because almost
everybody
is either too red or Too Blue with it
when Candor needs to be purple
you understand
that's a big one I really hope that
somebody leaves with that
I'm going to touch on patients before I
go into q a
the reason most people struggle with
patients is probably another massive
thing that's going on in this room
professionally and personally
most people want to accomplish things
financially or status wise
to impress other people and that is a
huge vulnerability
the keeping up with the Joneses or how
people judge them based on their money
their accolades their status is
destroying people this goes back to 20
minutes ago of trying to impress people
you don't even like
right so the lack of patience
has been one of the most obvious things
unlike Candor at 20 I already understood
it
you know I I thought that I was going to
be a great businessman but I spent 22 to
34 working for my dad's liquor store
building his business for him I built
his business from a 4 million to a 70
million dollar business and I never got
paid much money at all because it was a
family business and my dad's like yo
what do you complain about it's a family
business when I die you'll get it I'm
like Dad you have great DNA you're gonna
die at 94. I'm going to be 72.
try to do work out here trying to make
something happen and so you know but it
was my patience and my deep ambition to
do something great for my parents who
did great for me that allowed me to know
that even though at 34 I barely had any
money based especially on my crazy
ambitions that I would be able to get to
it because life is long because you can
make things happen can you can build
Brick by Brick and so patience is
hurting a lot of people here in a
million different ways people are
shortcutting to decisions making
decisions on short-term values versus
long-term realities and I highly highly
recommend a deeper falling in love with
patients how are we doing Q a we've got
Runners cool I'm going to speak for a
little bit more but I really want people
to start thinking about the question
they want to ask and by the way I know
some of you may know me and I'm thrilled
to talk about marketing I think about
that quite a bit you know whatever that
may be and I think about marketing not
just like let's sell sneakers and soda
marketing is how the whole world Works
Communications how the whole world works
you may want to raise money to cure a
disease because your family's been
affected by it you may want somebody to
be the mayor of your town you may want a
lot of things happen I don't think
anyone here is confused that marketing
and communication dictates the
temperament and the decisions of human
beings and so a couple just two little
things on that first and foremost if you
want something to happen in the world
and you're going to be the one that is
trying to make it happen
and you may have lots of opinions about
social media because everyone does now
it's still the platform to make what you
and this room want to happen happen
because it's free
you're more than welcome to buy
television ads go pop out fifty thousand
dollars a spot knock yourself out you're
more than welcome to run an ad in the
newspaper the problem is that 80 year
old that's your friend is the only one
reading it
you're more than welcome to have an
opinion on Tick Tock China this and Mark
Zuckerberg that you can have any opinion
you want but let me just say one thing
in this room if you're going to be a
marketer you need to be agnostic you
need to be unemotional
you need to care about where the
attention of society is period end of
story the biggest reasons people are not
good at marketing or making something
happen is they have an ideology of what
it should be
the kids shouldn't be on these phones
all the time they are
just to remind you you are
and so on the marketing front
social will continue to be the
underpriced game and then something else
will come along when I was coming up the
game it was email email was new
kids you want to hear a good one a lot
of people in this room really didn't
want to have email
some people I still have people I do
work with who have people print out the
email for them so they can read it to
this day
I just want to say one thing on
technology and then we'll move into q a
please stop fighting technology
technology is undefeated against your
opinions
I understand you have an opinion about
AI good news AI doesn't care what your
opinion is Ron
how many watch this how many people I
need people to be honest lying is the
devil
by show of hands and raise it high
because usually people like to do this
on this question
a show of hands who in here was this
person you had a Blackberry and you
loved it because it had all the buttons
and everything
and when the iPhone came out you said
I'm never getting an iPhone it doesn't
even have the buttons my Blackberry is
good and now you have an iPhone raise
your hand hi
this those hands and by the way this is
a pretty OG crowd I could go one
generation back there were people
rolling around the world in the mid 90s
with a beeper
who said I'm never getting a cell phone
my beeper's more than I don't need
people to call me anytime they want
let them beep me and I'll call them back
and the amount of people in this room
that said they would never be on social
media and now they spend all their time
on Facebook arguing with people
humans are horrible at this people said
they wouldn't get the car people said
they wouldn't buy a television because
the radio was perfect
people will always demonize tomorrow
because of fear
humans are scared
and unfortunately other humans figure
that out and weaponize it against us and
I'm not talking about governments though
they're very good at it
I'm talking about school
I'm talking about school telling you
that if you get D's and F's you're going
to be a loser meanwhile
does anybody realize how broken school
is in 2023 does anybody have children
here from K to 12 raise your hands
you you know how bad it is right we're
literally telling kids to memorize stuff
and regurgitate it when they have
literally the answers on their phone
these kids are chat gbting the answer
writing papers in one minute and I'm
like good
and school's like bad for what
school has broken us I'm being dead
serious on this and I'm not trying to be
mad at school like I and don't get
confused I believe that education is the
most important thing in the world
I just think it should be relevant to
the world we actually live in
and asking our children to spend 12
years of their lives memorizing stuff
and then re-spitting it out every three
months is the most asinine thing I've
ever seen in a world of the internet
exists with the answers to the question
on their phone at all times these kids
are disenchanted because they're smart
not the reverse
so that's just that
all right I think it's time for Q now
thank you for having me thank you
all right
let's let's get into some real stuff
those are the philosophies there's many
others some of you have seen some of it
read the books but I'd love to go into q
a let's not be bashful I know how this
goes just raise your hand who's got a
question
sure I'm in back there uh Gary can you
talk about how you deal with failure
with all your uh success you've had to
overcome failure in the past and second
question if you can talk about where you
see AI playing in society's future
social record yeah I'll go to the second
one AI is going to eat up everything if
you leave there's a lot of mental things
we talked about here as a practical
thing every person here
actually I'm going to assume a lot of
this crowd has not gone into AI yet it's
new and I'm just I'm generalizing but by
show of hands how many people here have
not played with an AI app or an AI
website yet like really done AI work
raise your hands if you haven't yet
that's what I figure so thank you please
please
because a lot of the hands will remember
this you not doing stuff with AI is just
like the thing you made fun of your
parents for not doing with the internet
this is the Internet 1992. it's that big
it's not going away and it will make
your life so much better when you're in
the kitchen saying hey Alexa can you
order me food for two friends one's
lactose intolerant order now boom and
that saves you 18 minutes of going to
the website or calling or being on your
Seamless app or ubereats this is going
to make your life better like everything
of course there'll be some things that
aren't good
but there aren't some things that are
good about everything nothing has been
in like alcohol has some bad things
right a car like everything has bad and
good please don't do the AI what you've
done to everything else it's going to be
a part of our lives so it's going to
affect brother it's gonna affect
everything
when I say everything everything so the
quicker you get used to it like the
better your life will be period end of
story
as far as failures my man I fail almost
every day when you're an entrepreneur
you're failing I'm failing constantly
how do I deal with it by not giving a
[__] what you think about my failures
your failures are your failures the
reason everyone struggles with failures
is because you actually worry about
someone's opinion of your failures
I'm playing
you think I care about somebody sitting
in the stands watching me play saying
you stink you stink you're sitting
I'm playing
I fail every I fail all the time the key
is to make them micro failures not macro
failures see people don't have that
definition down I micro fail
if I macro failed I'd be out of business
I would have a job that's macro failing
I don't macro fail I don't take those
kind of risks I'm too smart
but Micro failing every day I hire
someone every day that ends up stinking
I we have a pitch we don't win I post
something that should have been great
and it did it like I'm losing all the
time the key for everyone here to get
more comfortable with losing is
realizing they're valuing people in the
stands
judging them on the court
you're playing you really care what
somebody else is telling you about how
you're raising your child
get out of here
as if they don't suck at parenting too
uh we're by the way this is the whole
thing right now in America we're
obsessed with telling everybody
everything about everything they're
doing wrong without realizing how much
we're doing wrong we are in judgment
City
we are in finger-pointing City
I deal with losing very easy I just
don't care what anybody thinks about my
losing
definitely not people I don't know and
not even my own parents I want to make
them proud I love them with all my heart
I have no intent of losing
but if you're living you're losing and
we have to get a lot more comfortable
with losing so much of the depression
and anxiety of the youth today is not
because of social media it's because we
as parents demonized losing they're
scared to lose
and we have to start cheering for losing
losing is just part of the game My
name's Andre Andre pleasure for being
here I'm glad to be here I hope I'm not
alone in this but uh how do folks uh you
know either discover or confirm what
they were born to do people like I feel
like I love that there's a couple things
yep you know but how do you really
discover it and then hold on to the mic
when you say there's a couple things
have you gone out and tasted and tried
to go for those couple things
yes and not fully but that second part
right this half pregnant thing
no really it's a big thing in my mind
I'm really glad you asked this question
I feel that people are trying this all
goes back to the thing I've been talking
about the whole time subtly
stop valuing other people's opinions
the reason he said not bully is he
didn't go all the way because
subconsciously there's a fear that it's
not going to work out will this make
enough money to stay sustain my like
most of the reason people don't go for
their dream is because they don't think
they'll make enough money to sustain
their life either their family's too
practical or they're insecure there's
too many variables
my big thing is I don't this is why I
want you to hang out Andre with a 90
year old you'll be more scared to not go
for it after hanging out with people
that literally when I tell you when you
hang out with the 80 to 100 year old set
all you see in their faces regret
you know you'll see joy and happy but if
you look if you look for what we're
trying to learn from them of like what
did you do that I can learn from it's
all regret brother
you will be far more scared to wake up
one day and say why didn't I go for
being a piano star
why wasn't why didn't I try to be a
stand-up comic
you know why didn't I move to Sweden
whatever it is be a cook be a
professional video game player whatever
it is
you will be fearful of that so much more
than your sister your uncle or your
spouse or your best friend laughing at
you when you stop doing what you're
doing and you go for this thing I get
I'll give you a big one one thing I talk
a ton about that boy I can't find anyone
talking about this is if you were in
debt or if you're living a life where
you're like kind of never getting over
the hump sell your home
and go rent a smaller home sell your
home and go live the amount of 35 year
olds right now that should sell their
home or stop paying for their apartment
and move back in with their parents is
high they can reset save some money have
some time with their parents which I
know is like not everyone loves that but
a lot of people would love that a lot of
people do like their parents I would
love that but their pride won't let them
do that because everybody will judge
them you sold your house and now you
live with your parents you're a loser
as if that person is living this is the
whole game
so my man the reason you're half
pregnant is
something is stopping you from doing it
and I promise you that something is
judgment about from others
and so you already know what things you
want to do Gary I can't find my passion
yes you can every one of you can tell me
what you love most
mine's the New York Jets
right so what am I doing I'm trying to
build the biggest businesses in the
world so I can buy the Jets and finally
win a [__] Super Bowl
but everyone everyone here knows what
they like they're scared to admit it
there's there's
in here that love ballet they're scared
to say it
we all know I will never believe anyone
that says I don't know no no you're
scared to admit
you're scared to go for it
and so that's what I'm trying to push
for
hi darling
hey Gary my name is
such a big fan of yours thank you
sweetie thank you sweetie let's talk
about now fear confronting fear and
resistance to change there's a lot of
people that have the mentality of if
it's not broken it's not safe right
um we've been doing this forever let's
not change this is how we got here
yep so when you want to bring something
new and uh to a leader or your manager
yep how would you advise us to approach
that and also help we Face our fears
thank you you're welcome so the first
one's really interesting I have this
framework that worked and don't forget I
have an agency that means we get hired
by companies and we're trying to tell
them what to do none of our clients do
the full thing that I want them to do
they still think running television
commercials on network TV is a better
way for you to buy something which is
just insane to me
um and I tell my team all the time
because they're very frustrated because
we're Progressive I'm like look
everybody makes the same mistake in the
question you're making they're in the
business of convincing
I'm not in the business of convincing
I'm in the business of conviction
I can't convince you up here in 45
minutes
we don't know each other like that
boy do I have conviction and everything
that came out of my mouth and for some
of you that might be enough
at this moment literally today was the
only day that some of the things I said
are going to penetrate there are people
who follow me for 10 years and will
email me and say I've heard you say the
same thing for 10 years and today was
the day
which is what keeps me motivated saying
the same 13 things 8 000 different ways
on every different platform
and so you have to when you go into your
next meeting don't try to convince them
have conviction in what you believe
humans will feel that
right and you just gotta
right it's just an everyday thing it's
the same thing of I always think that
working out is a great comp for life
like most people just want to do eight
push-ups
and think like it'd be all good
you know like they just they don't
realize that it's an everyday thing it's
an everyday thing like everybody here
can be in better shape eat healthier and
exercise
you know the blueprint you just it's
hard to do
everyone's looking for the shortcut
so you just have to keep pushing keep
pushing and then you have to go into
accountability
if you're pushing every day respectfully
for three years and it's not happening
and it's bothering you like that well
then quit
this is my big thing complaining
is the worst
complaining drives me batshit crazy
especially when you have options
you can't quit because you're getting
paid 200 000 a year and your lifestyle
well guess what
have the humility to get your lifestyle
down if you're so unhappy at work which
is where you spend the majority of your
life
then return your Lexus
and drive a [__] Dodge
if you're so unhappy don't go on two
vacations that are bougie do a
staycation if you're so unhappy stop
buying five dollar Starbucks coffee and
make your 18 Cent coffee at home
you are in control
so conviction conviction conviction
your boss is driving you crazy it's
never going to happen it's eating up
your soul leave
because you can
two years from pension three years from
retirement you still can leave or eat it
because that's your strategy and you
want it but shut your mouth
if you know why you're doing it and
you're just eating it for another three
years eat it and stop complaining
because you're driving us all down with
you
thank you foreign
go ahead you can go here and we'll go to
you next we got him next
sir sir Captain Durfee uh so first you
know talking about Candor I have to be
completely honest and say that when I
heard that you're coming the only time
that I knew of you was on YouTube uh
going to garage sales and stuff so I
thought we're gonna get really good at
going on
I'm fully open with it can I say
something sir yeah my garage sale videos
that I know people have seen
that's me listening I I was getting you
know I would talk about my story and be
like hey I didn't have anything either
and then I saw Twitter and I invested in
it and I invested 25 000 into it and it
made X right and I started just getting
these emails like okay Gary good for you
but like I don't twenty five thousand
dollars to invest in the next winner and
I was like cool let me show you what I
did when I had two dollars to my name I
drew around I drove around New Jersey
went to garage sales I bought stuff in
high school I sold it at flea markets in
the shanic station in Hunterdon County
and then the internet came along and
then I sold it on eBay those garage sale
videos that all my bougie business
friends make fun of me for because
they're like you look so stupid and this
and that that goes back to the crowd I'm
like you may think I look stupid but I
get 10 emails a week from people that
had 400 to their family's name and made
six thousand dollars this summer buying
stuff at garage sales for a dollar or
Goodwill and selling it for 20. means a
lot to me those videos
so actually following up with that you
know you talk about empathy but then you
also talk about not caring about
people's opinions you know how do you
balance empathy with not caring about
empathy thank you sir empathy is having
the capacity and compassion to care
about other people's feelings
not caring about other people's opinions
is based on being secure in your own
skin and not valuing judgment
they're very very easy to balance though
the question is absolutely right it's
all emotional Frameworks for me it's the
game of being selfless and being selfish
you know for me
having compassion and empathy like it's
even the entire speaking style I have
right now like to me I sit here and I'm
just literally in real time right now
what can I say that will bring value
what can I say that brings value as far
as I've also cursed four times sir I
know there's people in here that don't
like that
I respect that I'm actually empathetic
to that if you grew up in a household or
were taught a certain way where that's a
horrible thing you're not going to like
that I grew up in Jersey so you know
it's a little it's a little hard for me
to contain it but I'm empathetic to the
judgment on the flip side I'm also aware
that I'm okay with that judgment because
if that's what you took out of this talk
we've got to work on all the things
we're talking about here to level up the
Consciousness so I think it's I think
it's very balancable I think that
they're just both very hard you know
this is this is 40 years of practice one
of the great things that happened to me
parents that have poor students let me
give you an Insight that's left field
truly not being talked about
what allowed me to be who I am is that I
got poor grades and every teacher and
every friend's parent told me I'd be a
loser but I knew I wasn't
I knew I wasn't because I made more
money than everyone selling lemonade
I knew I wasn't because when it snowed I
got a shovel and rang every doorbell
I knew I wasn't because the world was
telling me the truth not the systems and
so I got practice
a lot of parents reinforce School
yeah you're you this is bad without
realizing school has no impact on
someone's truth in life
and so we need to think about those
things and I just got a lot of practice
of tuning out the noise because the
noise was telling me one thing but I was
living another I'll give you another one
the greatest thing I wish on everyone
besides health is living the first 10
years of their life in a household
that's extremely happy with very little
money that was mine
because I was brought up in a way where
I realized very quickly oh money has no
impact on happiness I grew up the
happiest little boy on Earth we had
nothing I wish that on everybody because
you get you get conditioned you
understand and so I think a lot about
these things it's practicing it's
emotional practice
emotional practice we talk about
physical practice we don't talk about
emotional practice so I would I think it
comes down to practicing like truly
having a bad day where people are
throwing judgment you and just like
knowing yourself enough to be like I'm
just gonna go golf because that's what
helps me or I'm going to watch sports
because that's what helps me or you know
I'm gonna listen to music like
practicing that's what I do every time
I'm having a struggle I push myself into
something that gives me escapism from
that struggle and getting conditioned we
need more emotional practice
my man
um how are you brother I just want to
say that I will see you on YouTube
Today's talk and you inspire so many
people right and I just want to know
who's your inspiration who's your hero
thank you brother so I've always
answered this question the same and I've
just recently figured out how to add to
it so historically it's always been my
parents they came to this country at 22
years old I lived in a studio apartment
the size of a third of this stage with
seven eight family members like it was
rough they worked every minute I watched
my Mom raise three kids solo doing
everything for us like my dad used to
wake up before I saw him and got home
after I went to sleep just worked work
so there's nobody even within their
realm however I will say this brother
lately I've realized there is a certain
other thing that inspires me to no end
so I live in Manhattan
and I take a lot of flights because I
travel a lot and a lot of those flights
are day trips so I actually take a lot
especially in the last 10 years a lot of
6 a.m flights so if you take a 6 a.m
flight you're kind of leaving the
apartment at like 4 30 right
and there's something that's just so
obvious to me when I'm leaving at 4 30
especially today would have been a
perfect day when it's like dark and
gloomy and you know I live in a city and
we're going to Newark or JFK or
LaGuardia so I'm driving through the
city usually to get to one of the
airports
and you know it's like 4 30 and like you
just woke up and even though I'd like to
close my eyes in the car I'm up so like
I'm just kind of like looking out the
window this is the scene that I just
always you kind of wipe off the right
and I'm looking out the window these
humans that this is what gets me to
gratitude
the amount of people I see
you know I'll just paint you the picture
that 52 year old woman that I see coming
out of the subway
at 4 55 a.m with two bags in her hand
and I start making up scenarios brother
I'm like man
she just lost her husband I'm serious
this is what I do this is back to mental
training what I'm training there is
gratitude
Right This Woman's it's 4 55 in the
morning she's got two bags carrying [__]
I'm like she she might have lost her
husband recently she has three kids to
take care of this is her second job now
she's doing six to nine before she goes
into you know what I mean and it's just
like that person the people out there
that grin like bite their tongue and
just put their head down
to provide financially and emotionally
for their family with all sorts of
adversity
and don't complain
that person bro for me is number one no
Elon no no Tom definitely not Tom
[__] Brady no you know no no no no no
like Oprah no no people that are on the
gram or not me not those people like the
people that nobody talks about that are
the the same way the military and the
services and the police number
foundational that get overlooked these
people these millions of people who just
grin it
you know we everyone right now is
thinking about a person like that that
they know of or was important to their
life the people
whose shoulders we stand on
in our families not just in our world
and so I'm so inspired by them you know
people you know you know when you're
young you're like trying to achieve you
got Ambitions you're looking up to
things one of the reasons I put out the
content I put out my man is because for
all the conversations about Rolexes and
Lambos and like those are just facades
so many of the people that have 10
million followers on these play I know
them they're not happy like that
they're not content like that
that's the makeup
the people that are just really putting
it out there and doing the right things
for the people they love
at their inconvenience
that inspires me to know and my man you
know I'm not impressed that I am good at
making money that was a god-given gift
I'm impressed that I'm nice to people
and so I think we have to start
championing that and I think the person
that's most admirable in the world
is the work person that is dealing with
the most adversity
and doesn't complain I admire that to
the end
thank you so much for taking the time
today for us thank you what's your name
Jeannie Fortunato Genie so I have a 17
and 18 year old yes 18 year olds in
Seton Hall doing great she was up and
running 17 year olds graduating in June
zero Direction yes I'm looking to give
him an elevator speech like it's okay
that you don't know what you're doing
but everybody's like oh Joey's in Seton
Hall what's Angel's doing
I'm like
uh we don't know what you know Road he's
taking at any advice on a good elevator
speech or a 17 year old yeah really sure
let's start with this how do you feel
about it I'm fine whatever he chooses do
you feel like he knows that oh yeah yeah
so what's the problem
17 year old dose he doesn't know how to
handle the pressures of everybody saying
okay your sister's insane of course
Angie needs to figure out how to not
value other people's opinions you this
whole thing you need to tell it's one
thing that angel knows that you're good
with it when when you see Ange rolling
and whether it's a friend whether it's a
sibling or a cousin right you need to
every time you as a parent to a 17 year
old sees that your his uncle came over
and he was a little hot on it you know
can you think of the three or four
people that you feel are most bringing
the most pressure even though they love
him are bringing the pressure you need
to really [__] on those people to inch
I'm serious when Uncle Don comes over
and Uncle Don is coming from Pure Love
he wants Ange to be good when I was your
right when Uncle Don leaves you need to
look angel in the face and be like Uncle
Don's a [__] idiot
you have to you have to you see what I
mean you have to you have to decrease
the value of the of the voices so that
he can have room to feel safe you're one
place but your mom right he needs to
know that all those other voices are
wrong
you have to judge the judger the thing
that I do for a lot of young people is
when they're struggling and I'll talk to
them they're like I'm like yeah but
stinks at this or did it as bad at that
or why don't you tell Uncle Don to stop
drinking
I'm being dead serious I know it's like
therapy is none of your business
no no you need to undermine them I I
know it no I'm really I'm being serious
it's going to help them because that
goes into too much like poster you need
to teach them he's 17. so even though
he's a kid he's he's starting to go
through that transition you can teach
him real life
you know like people don't like to talk
about the truth
you have like an aunt come over and
cause all this Ruckus but you know the
ant was a mess until she was 40. tell
the 17 year old that the aunt was a mess
until she was 40. it it really I you
know I I get it and it you know and
obviously I'm trying to use some extreme
examples for a giggle and to put into
perspective you don't need to tell them
a secret alcoholic is in your family but
but you definitely need to put things
into perspective on the flip side and
this is where it gets dangerous you
can't create entitlement
right and you're and that's hard right
so it's this weird balance of like hey
everyone sucks but you might suck too if
you don't do anything
right like it's when I tell you
parenting
is just like politics right now we've
gone way too extreme and everybody has
to get to the middle as fast as humanly
possible so it's like hey kid there's
unlimited people that don't know
anything at 17. the world is filled with
people that sucked at school and don't
know what they want to do
comma you're not going to be laying at
home doing nothing no right so you don't
need to go to school but you're going to
work and by the way if you want to work
at Walmart good if you want to be an
entrepreneur fine you but but you're
going to have to do that
and yeah I got you because I love you
and you can stay here but I'm not giving
you any money here's where parents get
caught they talk big game but then they
pay for the kids Uber they talk big game
but they get them an equinox membership
they talk big game but they one of the
parents undermines the whole Ship by
slipping them 100 bucks quietly and be
like you can't do that if that kid's
such a big boy and he's going to do it
without school he needs to stand on his
own two feet you can do subtle things
like put a roof over his head which is
already remarkable
but parents undermine their words with
their actions
so he's good you know you're lucky that
it's a great kid I don't I don't you
don't worry for a second a lot of people
don't most so many kids that are bad at
school are the ones I least worry about
right I'm much honestly me personally
I'm much more fearful of the great
student because they're being taught to
be a robot
like to me the kid but where I get
really scared is unlike 1985 1996 2000 a
lot of those 17 year olds went out and
got a hard job and learned it and then
excelled 2023 has got this weird mix
where parents are like cool but then
like subsidize their life
you need to make him stand on his own
two feet that will teach him everything
and you but you could be absolutely
emotionally supportive just not
financially supportive that's where
parents really lose their way because
then the kid doesn't understand why he
needs to
I mean we all saw this when the
government pays you to stay home more
than you get to go to work everybody
wants to stay home
I'm the most motivated of all time if
the government wants to give me the Jets
right now I'd understand why that would
trick me
but it's not real and that's his version
you're welcome
uh my name is Hanson and uh handsome
handsome oh man
I thought I just met the best name ever
go ahead brother
um I have a uh I have a selfish question
please you should put it on the side and
I'm curious about social media trends
yes uh what are your thoughts on like
short form versus long form both work
what are you what are you better at
uh I typically do long form stuff but
I'm just getting into short form do long
form and then edit you see how I do it
do long form and then post edit for
short form to bring awareness to long
form
you understand a couple other things
it's always about organic reach what's
giving you more organic reach in the
beginning right now Facebook reels
it doesn't come natural most people have
moved on from Facebook they don't think
but Facebook reels for under 35 is
crushing so Facebook reels if you
haven't been doing YouTube shorts for
sure for sure especially if you're long
forms on YouTube and then the obvious
Tick Tock and Instagram things that
nature okay do you see any other apps
that you should there's there's two apps
that are in like alpha alpha alpha mode
Clapper in case Tick Tock gets banned I
think could be a winner and lemon eight
which is done by bite dance which could
also get banned but as you know
Instagram based those two but I'm not
ready to really talk about them because
I don't like guessing but I'm watching
and those but you wouldn't get the
reason it's not a good use right now is
I'm watching to be more right to when it
when it happens it's not happening on
those two platforms like that yet
whereas with Facebook reels and YouTube
shorts you could post your first YouTube
short and it could work
you got it
hi my name is another social media
question please generate a big audience
and so it's kind of a two-parter so one
what is the number one impact social
media has in your day-to-day life and
the second is how did you generate like
that following from scratch
the number one thing it brings to me is
knowing what all of you care about
so I don't really consume social media
for me
I consume social media to understand
what 8 billion people on Earth care
about
so I'm watching like if I wasn't an
entrepreneur if I didn't have that I
feel like I would have ended up being
like you know those weird scientists
that go like to the mountains and like
watch ants for 30 years
that's I've got that in me like uh so
much of everything you heard today was
25 years of observing all of you
so that's the biggest value it brings to
me is like big things like oh my God
kids are fearing losing because the
eighth place trophies that was not like
something that was like observing the
DMS from kids along the way being like
but I'm scared but I'm just gonna like
why and you just talk and you just talk
and you're like oh right you've never
lost
everything's been covered up I mean this
is the craziest parents actually go to
school now and argue for a better grade
for kids
that's insane
like we've just done too much too many
training wheels and so
um
that's what it does for me as far as me
what I did well that I want for him
handsome and everybody else is what I do
really well is I make what I want to
make not what I think is going to do
well in likes and followers
so back to the garage sale but like I
knew that I would get judged by my fancy
business friends but I didn't care I
wanted to make it because I knew that
was going to bring value uh uh I started
making wine videos that's how I started
I know a lot about wine I made wine
videos I'm recently starting to make
them again because I miss it
it's not doing as well as my business
content but I don't care
and I think I think the more authentic
you can be the more real you can be
people can smell [__] from we're all
animals we're sensing it and I think the
reason I've connected is people know I'm
authentic and I think they value that
and I think we all value that and so I
would make content you want to make not
what you think will do well
thank you
thank you thank you
so much
thank you